south korea reported its first
coronavirus case the very same day as
the u.s
but south korea has kept its infection
and death rates
much lower than we have they took the
virus seriously
and they acted quickly the government
was able to make
a very fast move to identify and isolate
patients
something they're doing is working so we
should be doing that
in general here life is pretty normal
seoul feels just as busy as it always
has
there's lots of traffic on the roads and
restaurants and cafes are full of people
there's never been the kind of deep
economic damage
that other places have had so it really
is an all-around
success story i'm here in korea
to see how korea is living with the
virus
more effectively really than any other
country
in the world
[Music]
we're heading out of town to the
headquarters of the korea center for
disease control and prevention
which is really the front-line agency in
containing covet 19
here they are really at the center of
this incredibly successful
year that korea has had
this is park young june the agency's
director of epidemiological
investigations
he's been working 90 plus our weeks
since the pandemic began
park was in charge of the government's
response to the first major outbreak
back in february
which began at the xinjiangji church of
jesus in the city of daegu
the religious sect xinchangi is at the
heart of south korea's kobe 19
outbreak more than half of the nation's
confirmed cases are found to be linked
to its members
of
with numbers rising fast park and his
colleagues made a series of decisions
that would set the tone for korea's
response to the pandemic
they quarantined everyone who had been
inside the affected church building
tested them all and then set about
tracing the contacts of
anyone who had tested positive the
approach was aggressive but highly
specific
avoiding a widespread lockdown and the
outbreak was under control within a
month
there have been other outbreaks since
but south korea has succeeded for the
most part in bringing them under control
while never
um much of that strategy emerged from
south korea's experience with another
deadly pathogen
the mers virus in 2015. 126 people in
south korea have now been infected with
middle east respiratory syndrome
the mers outbreak the biggest outside of
saudi arabia has now killed 10 people
mers spread mostly within hospitals and
wasn't nearly as contagious as covid 19
but it was much more lethal 38 south
koreans ultimately died
and the government was determined to be
better prepared the next time
you have
[Music]
korea ramped up testing much faster than
other countries
at the beginning of the pandemic it now
has much greater capacity than it needs
and that could help control the virus
worldwide
we are headed out to a satellite
city of seoul to see a company called
osan healthcare
they've really been on the front line of
efforts to test
for the coronavirus
osan has been exporting test kits all
over the world
since very early in the pandemic
currently working to dramatically
increase the availability of rapid
is currently making 2.5 million rapid
tests per week
all intended for export i suited up to
get a look at the production line
this is definitely one of the cleaner
spaces i've ever been to
if you look at the floor it's just
there's not a fleck
even of dust so the way this basically
works
is that we have this big roll of very
special
paper it then dips the paper into this
bath
of reagent that's the stuff that
actually makes the test work makes it
sensitive to covet 19
antigens and over there it's cut up into
strips
so the test strips then end up in this
enormous machine
here and the job here is to make sure
there are no problems or imperfections
and then put them in a little plastic
housing a colleague of mine
was here earlier in the year i think in
may and
said they didn't have any of this when
she visited so
this is all new it has been designed and
implemented with pretty incredible speed
this is the finished product uh the test
housing is in this little candy wrapper
here
uh and these cost about five dollars so
the idea
is that these tests which are rapid can
really put a dent in the pandemic by
giving a lot more people
much faster and cheaper access to
testing which has been such a bottleneck
in so many countries
[Music]
the second main component of korea's
virus strategy and arguably the most
important
is contact tracing verifying the
movements of cobit 19 patients and
determining who they spent time with
this is also where applying lessons from
korea to other countries becomes a
little more complicated
i don't know where to go from here let
me see this
epidemiological yeah so we are at
uh city hall in inchon which is a port
city just west of seoul
and we're going to meet one of their
contact tracing team
to understand what happens when there is
a confirmed case
zhang hanaram is a military doctor who
leads the six-person tracing team for
this city of three million
it's painstaking incredibly
time-consuming work
for the first month or so of the
pandemic zhang slept in the office
and his hours are still very long so
when you do
get a confirmed case what is your system
for tracking all the all the contacts
contact tracers in korea have access to
a huge amount of data
whether that's credit card transactions
cctv
gps from telecommunications companies
and that allows them to determine
with immense accuracy exactly where
someone was and when
now that's a very potent epidemiological
tool
but as you can imagine raises all kinds
of privacy concerns
um
that's not to say everyone here is happy
with the system
zhang told me that he sometimes
encounters resistance to his
investigations
he blames one particularly uncooperative
subject for a significant outbreak in
[Music]
[Music]
as successful as korea's strategy has
been this stigma around the virus
seems to have been a source of real
hardship for some
i got a glimpse of the phenomenon while
speaking to a restaurant owner in
itaewon
a vibrant area for nightlife in seoul
linus kim has lived in korea for almost
a decade and owns a restaurant called
linus barbecue
i asked him if he knew anyone in korea
who'd gotten the virus
they're yeah uh yeah i just can't reveal
them
yeah really these people don't want to
oh of course not
it really was a witch hunt like back in
april it was widely thought if you had
coven that it was grounds to be
terminated from your job
the stigma has hurt the bottom line for
lioness and other business owners in
itaewon
in may there was an outbreak that began
in a nightclub here
and customers stayed away from the whole
neighborhood for weeks
it's not clear when it will fully
recover
nemo kim who owns crown b bar says he's
been managing thanks to low overhead and
a loyal clientele
but business is still very tough like if
you had a virus case here
at this bar people wouldn't come back to
the bar right now you have to close them
completely yeah like you would go out of
business you think if you had a buyer of
course
the thing is that it's a mindset of
people like they will know
that you have the fires yeah then i
don't think they will come you know
as difficult as this year has been linus
told me that as an american expat
he's been impressed at korean's ability
to take the pandemic in their stride
south koreans particularly are just so
used to these life-threatening
like these things that would normally
paralyze any other nation
even if things are like not doing well
in e-tail owner or
you know somewhere there's another part
of korea where it is business as usual
i i know there will be a day where
things kind of level off and
i just hope it's sooner than later
i visited south korea in early november
and in the weeks since we've seen how
the virus can re-establish
itself even when it seems to be under
control 620 new cases have been
confirmed
a nine-month high seoul is bearing the
brunch
as the end of the year festive season
gets underway people have been told to
cancel their plans
we don't yet know how this outbreak will
play out but it's clear the authorities
are concerned
social distancing rules have repeatedly
been tightened in and around seoul
and there are now more restrictions on
daily life than there have been for most
of the year
during my visit though society was still
quite open
and i went to an event that showed me
how koreans were adapting to their new
normal
we're here at jomsha stadium in seoul
for a playoff game between two of the
most popular teams in the korean
baseball league and as you can see
behind me
there are spectators spectator sports
are back
capacity is limited there are all kinds
of other rules around things like
wearing masks
there is a gate set up where everyone
coming in has to scan a qr code that's
something everyone in korea has on their
phone
it's for contact tracing so you scan the
code it goes into a system and then the
government ultimately has a record
of everyone who is here every other seat
in the stands is actually
taped off so everyone has to sit
staggered
the chanting has been limited somewhat
because the authorities don't want
people
yelling a lot potentially spreading
droplets
it is a sporting event people are here
life goes on but it's different it's
changed
no one would mistake this for the free
coronavirus world
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
you